bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
rendez vous du mercredi consacrée à
l'eau qui l'épisode 5 était vraiment
sympa un gros délire de calme avant la
tempête
on voit clairement que la fin sera
proche que l'étau se resserre enfin
voilà avant que l'on commence n'oubliez
pas évidemment de vous abonner à la
chaîne pour ne louper aucune des
prochaines vidéos surtout que le grand
final de l'eau qui arrive la semaine
prochaine
donc voilà faut pas louper ça allait
bref let's go tout d'abord j'aimerais
parler d'un truc qui me chiffonne
je vais vous révéler un truc que j'aime
bien faire c'est regarder le trailer
final de la série entre chaque épisode
vu que le trailer est composée d'image
de l'entièreté de la série cela permet
de faire une mise à jour à chaque fois
en mode
ah bon bah ça on l'a vu ça on l'a pas
encore vu alors qu'est ce que ça peut
évoquer et là il reste qu'un seul
extrait enfin plutôt 2 que l'on n'a pas
encore vu dans la série
c'est un lot qui triomphe en applaudi
devant son trône un trône qui rappelle
beaucoup celui das garde et là faut
qu'on parle déjà sachez que j'adore
discuter avec vous à propos de la série
lire vos commentaires voir ce que vous
avez pensé de la série ou de l'épisode
en question est d'ailleurs par rapport à
ça j'aimerais réagir à une certaine
inquiétude que j'ai remarqué parfois
dans les commentaires rassurez-vous
jamais je ne spoilerai l'épisode du jour
via la miniature où le titre nous sommes
sur une chaîne de théorie donc
évidemment je fais des théories et du
coup bas
ce n'est que de la spéculation il n'y a
pas de spoil je ne me permettrais jamais
et puis toute façon vous êtes prévenu au
début de l'épisode avec la petite
modification attention spoil épisode 4 5
6 etc bref à parenthèse refermée il est
vrai que nous avons beaucoup parlé de
camps c'est un antagoniste qui fait
réellement fantasmes et un pour la suite
du mc eu mais dans le fond il est
fortement possible que le méchant de la
série comme vous l'avez dit serait un
lot qui en fait c'est même clairement
l'idée la plus plausible
pourquoi tout simplement car le thème de
la série el okki plus nous avançons plus
nous voyons de l'eau qui différent
inspiré de comics comme classique loki
kid loki loki président etc
cela coule même presque de source que
celui derrière tout ça serait un lot qui
nous suivons un lot qui il s'allie à une
autre lot qui il y à une stigmatisation
des lots qui sont bannis pour la plupart
dans ce néant bref ça fait beaucoup de
l'eau qui est la technique des images du
trailer qui ne sont pas encore apparu à
l'écran appuie encore plus cette idée
sans oublier la vision de sylvie quant à
la touche et la brume daliot tu l'as
grosses créatures le chien de garde de
là où se cache le méchant entre
guillemets nous voyons un manoir un
manoir avec une sorte de dôme sur le
dernier étage avec cette couleur dorée
nous pouvons vite faire le rapprochement
avec les dernières images du trailer
manquants d'ailleurs le manoir est situé
sur un îlot hors du temps et nous voyons
une très grande ligne en continu
cela symbolise clairement le flux sacré
temporel à tous les coups sauf que
n'oublions pas que cela reste un trailer
et un trailer
c'est un petit peu une sorte d'outil de
manipulation ils peuvent nous faire
croire
mille et une choses par ce biais donc il
ya pour moi
trois possibilités concernant cette
dernière images manquantes qui est
officiel je le rappelle ça vient du
trailer officiel soit il s'agit du
véritable antagonistes
la véritable personne derrière tout ça
derrière le tva est donc un lot qui dans
l'idée on nous bassine depuis le début
que l'eau qui est à la recherche de son
glorieux destin mais qu'il échoue
toujours qu'il est destiné à être
poursuivi par la souffrance et bien
l'idée que celui derrière le tva est un
lot qui est assez vendeur car pourquoi
il n'existerait pas un lot qui qui lui a
réussi un lot qui qui aurait atteint son
glorieux destin et qui a le contrôle de
tout et qui justement met des bâtons
dans les roues des autres lots qui pour
rester le seul est l'ultime si on veut
lier ça aux comics l'idée de king l'eau
qui serait pas mal l'un des rares loki
qui gagne réellement un lot qui
supérieur aux autres
en tout point une thématique à mener
dans les dialogues entre mobius et loki
qui se sent lui aussi supérieur aux
autres
bref un lot qui bien plus puissant et
qui gagne néanmoins c'est quand même
très étrange que marvel spoil
l'antagoniste ultime via un trailer de
avant le tout début de la série alors
que c'est la thématique principale
depuis deux épisodes on veut savoir qui
est derrière tout ça donc c'est
incohérent
il se pourrait donc que cette image soit
notre lot qui triomphe ans après son
combat final comme l'a déclaré sylvie
après tout ça et là régneront sur le
flux temporel ou bien c'est tout
simplement un flashback un souvenir
après tout il ya des gens qui
l'applaudissent donc c'est bizarre si ce
n'est pas un flashback pourquoi il y a
des gens et que font-ils la danse eu
lieu précisément hors du temps et de
l'espace
à côté du flux sacré temporel enfin bon
maintenant si nous parlons du problème
de gang
effectivement on a beaucoup parlé de
gangs comme je le disais au début de la
vidéo des indices sont clairement là
c'est un personnage qui est lié à
pratiquement toutes les thématiques de
la série où même les entités de cette
dernière
genre le voyage dans le temps le tva
ramona et je peux vous dire même
alliotte a un lien avec kong
donc voilà kang arrivera c'est sûr mais
peut-être pas dans la série en fait tout
dépend de la vision de marvel à propos
de l'avenir du mc eu en général la
question d'une saison 2 est posée à
chaque nouvelle série marvel disney plus
la réponse à chaque fois et plus ou
moins sous-entendu que non mais
bizarrement pas pour l'eau qui car oui
l'eau qui est aujourd'hui gracié de la
saga du mc eu
il est hors du temps et de l'espace et
normalement il n'est pas sensé
réapparaître du moins pour le moment 1
évidemment dans la saga il va très
certainement continuer son aventure solo
et sa série ne dépend pas du tout des
avengers au final donc c'est là que
quand peut être intéressant si saison 2
il y à ce serait le moyen de pourquoi
pas l'introduire puisque tout le concept
de tva aurait déjà été établie tout le
concept de nexus de voyages temporels de
flux sacré et cetera
et si saison 2 il y a ce sera
certainement dans une période proche à
antoine trois films ou kangs va
apparaître la phase 4 étant déjà bien
chargé une petite saison 2 pour fin 2022
ou 2023 dans le courant permettrait de
lier tout ça est de créer la continuité
entre la série
et entre man 3 justement enfin bref cela
reste une possibilité
et d'ailleurs pour relier cela à ramona
ces dernières semblent être dans un mood
ou celui qui a créé le tva serait en
danger
sous-entendant clairement qu'elle
aimerait lui venir en aide s'allier à
lui qu'elle souhaiterait même
cherchèrent à lui plaire si son analyste
secret n'est pas kang c'est peut-être le
moyen d'instaurer kang avec cette
fameuse relation amoureuse des comics
entre lui et ramona
bref dans tous les cas la fin la série
law qui va nous proposer de la surprise
marvel c'est très bien géré la hype et
les mauvaises directions
ce n'est pas un hasard si tout le monde
voyait méphisto dans one la vision
l'arrêt faute diable dans la série law
qui n'est pas accidentel non plus les
indices sur kang pareil c'est pas du
hasard
ils savent et ils jouent avec nous et
connaissant le fonctionnement de ces
derniers sont véritablement capables de
nous prendre à revers avec ce dernier
épisode l'épisode 6 le fait est que nous
sommes face à une série centrée sur
l'eau qui est l'eau qui reste le dieu de
la malice silo qui est bien connu aux
yeux de tous
c'est pour ces trahisons la série a même
été vendus autour de ça à ses débuts on
ne sait pas comment vont réagir loki et
sylvie face au pouvoir ultime du temps
un pouvoir qui dépasse même les pierres
d'infinité comme montré dans le premier
épisode
la question du fameux glorieux destin
n'est pas rappelés par hasard à chaque
épisode
l'eau qui va possiblement faire face à
ce fameux glorieux destin quand il sera
face aux flux sacré temporel mais au
final quelle sera sa réaction
sylvie en a conscience qu'il est un lot
qui qu'ils peuvent riez à n'importe quel
moment
néanmoins n'oublions pas que le
cheminement de la série veut nous
montrer que l'eau qui a changé a évolué
et qu'il se dirige normalement vers la
meilleure version de lui même puis
n'oublions pas mobius beaucoup pensent
que ce dernier joue un double jeu
mais je ne pense pas personnellement je
me dis juste que la fin de mobius
pourrait être de retrouver une vie
normale après tous ces événements lui
permettre de faire du jet ski
un détail qui est devenu bien trop
présent au fil de la série
voilà attendons-nous à dos la dinguerie
la question du qui est derrière tout ça
est rappelé depuis maintenant deux
épisodes
l'épisode 6 sera clairement tourné
autour de cette question il faut
refermer la porte
nous sommes à la fin de la série mais
peut-être qu'au final cette histoire de
tva de flux temporel et cetera ne sera
pas véritablement terminée
surtout si la possibilité d'une saison 2
est présente à vous de me dire du coup
ce que vous en pensez en commentaire qui
est derrière tout ça quelle sera la
finalité de l'eau qui j'ai vraiment hâte
de vous lire évidemment n'oubliez pas le
petit pouce bleus et à vous abonner à la
chaîne c'est très important
et puis écoutez on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour le dernier
épisode de loki et avant ça on va se
retrouver pour black widow qui sort tout
juste aujourd'hui allait enfin voilà
écoutez c'était targo rock et que le
'lion' rares soit avec vous allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]